my son who is uh 11
uh was he saw the trailer for
deepwater horizon and he said i really
want to see that movie
and i said okay well i'm interested
because it's a little more sophisticated
than what
we usually take him to scene a little
more intense and i said i don't know if
you can
if we can see that moving he said i
really want to see it because i know
it's a true story i know it's about
hurting the environment and i want to
see it so i took him to see it
we both loved the movie but it looked to
me like you were doing your own stunts
in that movie
yeah uh you know i always i'll do
whatever's
required by the director but i'm not
that gung-ho like yeah let me you know
throw me off a building but uh
in this particular situation you know uh
pete
you know they wanted because these guys
were caught on fire a number of times uh
the guy that i played mike williams had
a lot of burn uh
burns on his body and so they were like
okay well you do this and i said yeah
you know we had
we thought you know in a safe
environment so stunt guys and you put
the protective suit on and then the gel
and then they kind of light you on fire
and i'm like wait a second usually they
say okay we got sound speed and we're
rolling and the cameras are up
they kind of let us on fire and walked
away right and i was like
dude we're supposed to like you want to
like roll then light me on fire
and then like stand really close with a
with a uh you know a little
you know fire hose or something but yeah
that was pretty clear that he lit you on
fire and then they all left to go get
lunch
yeah it was one it sounds like you were
on fire for 45 minutes
what it wasn't that long but it seems
like an eternity so i won't be
i won't be doing that anytime soon i did
one we did one stunt when we were just
starting on
this show where they uh did the gel and
all that and lit me on fire
and they said uh roll this way don't
roll that way and i was like okay i'll
do that and you're wearing a protective
suit and everything but it's still
you're on fire
and then they said whatever you do don't
stand and i said why they said because
then the wind will catch you
and the fire will just spread quickly
and your whole face which is unprotected
will be enveloped in flame
but they said that kind of like yeah you
might not want to do that
yeah yeah it didn't seem so it's very
serious stuff
it is it is i think yeah you know um
yeah why would you how would the hell
would you let them light you on fire for
a stunt anyway what was it for
i don't know i mean it's the thing is
all the time they tell me to do stuff
and i just do it
and most of the time it's a bet yeah
yeah
to settle a bed andy was here actually
when we were at a rehearsal and they had
a water buffalo here
and they were someone said get on the
water buffalo and there was no
someone people just were on their
iphones they were like yeah get on the
water buffalo and andy said
to his credit said don't get on a water
buffalo but like an idiot i was like
people think i should
so i got on the water buffalo this thing
is twice as big as this desk it threw me
i went up in the air right over there
and
landed and bounced on the concrete and
then andy was like told ya
you know i was nice yeah and then yeah
and then they set me on fire yeah